Hello everyone, welcome to another NCBI Minute.
Today I will talk about the advanced search
in dbGaP.
This first slide is just a reminder about
a few housekeeping details.
We will be recording and there is a link to
the YouTube channel.
Today we will talk about an advanced interface
to dbGaP, I assume if you are attending the
webinar you know a lot about it already.
I just want to introduce a little bit of information
about dbGaP, and then I'm going to show you
a couple of slides that show you the interfaces
I'm going to talk about, then we will go live
on a demonstration on how to do this.
So dbGaP stands for the database of genotypes
and phenotypes.
It contains human phenotype data and related
individual level molecular data.
There's a lot of studies in dbGaP encompassing
lots of different numbers of participants,
from a few to tens of thousands.
There are about 1 million people represented
in dbGaP, across 600 studies, it contains
information about the studies, molecular data,
medical images, research protocols, and questionaires.
Molecular data types include genotypes, expression
level, genomic sequence, epigenomic information,
somatic mutation, and human microbiome information.
In order to get that data you have to have
controlled access approval.
Here is a link to the homepage that talks
about how to go about doing that.
From the web point of view, the main way into
dbGaP is through the dbGaP homepage, which
is accessible from our homepage or from Google
or any search engine, you will just type in
dbGaP and get to this page.
The main search box on this page is basically
an Entrez search interface.
And you are probably familiar with those for
our molecular databases, and in fact PubMed
is an Entrez interface.
What we have available now on dbGaP is a separate
Advanced search page.
It makes it a little easier to find the data
you need; it's a better adapted interface
working with dbGaP data.
Click on the link shown on the home page,
you will go to that interface.
It is an alternative way to search dbGaP on
the web, finding studies and other things
you need.
Basically this is what you will call a faceted
search, you will filter the studies on the
right, that let you filter by variables, the
phenotype data sets, molecular datasets analyses,
study, keyword search, study design, molecular
data type, and marker sets.
You can do a keyword search across all of
these aspects of data.
While you are doing this and searching the
query, there is a sort of SQL query that is
formed, on the top you can adjust those; click
on them to remove them.
There is a link [www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/projects/gapsolr/facets.html]
that goes directly to this page.
What I want to do now is leave the slides
and take you to this faceted interface and
do a couple of simple examples to show you
how it works.
I'm going to escape out of PowerPoint and
switch to the web browser, set on the NCBI
homepage, if you want to follow along you
certainly can launch a web browser.
The quickest way to get to the dbGaP homepage,
one way to do this anyway, is to use the pulldown
list, select dbGaP, and click Search.
Here is the dbGaP homepage.
This is where a lot of documentation is.
The information about controlled access data
is here, if you want to learn more about that,
or anything you need to know about dbGaP is
available here.
I'm going to click on this Advanced Search
interface; it will take me to the new search
interface.
there are several tabs here, variables, phenotype
data sets, documents, molecular data sets,
analysis, and the number of all these things
available for searching.
Over here I have a set of filters, with the
numbers of things that each one of these aspects
I can filter by.
We will use these to get a particular kind
of data out of here.
Notice the filters on the left hand side change
whenever, for example if I click on this variables
tab, for instance, there is now a new filter
to filter by, Study, if I want to do that.
Likewise there are different filters further
down.
They pertain to that particular kind of data.
For example if I go over here and click on
Analyses, the number of studies changes dramatically.
There are 76 studies that have analyses available.
We will see that happen when we do our searches
today, when we go through our example.
I will start an example with the Studies tab
selected.
I will start out as I am interested in a particular
human disease, I will pick a disease focus.
I want to look up Type II diabetes.
I can see what is available by typing diabetes.
And i'm going to click the checkbox here where
you see eleven type II diabetes studies.
And then there might be other criteria I might
want to narrow this down by.
One thing you might want to do is to pay attention
to what kind of consent is required.
This varies a lot depending upon the particular
study.
In some cases you are restricted to doing
research on a particular topic.
The most general is General Research Use,
shown here.
I will pick a restricted one, General Research
Use plus Institutional Research Board approval.
I will check that one.
And so I'm left with a small set of two studies.
I'm sorry there are three studies.
One of them is a parent of the other two.
This is a fusion study, the Finland-United
States Investigation of NIDDM genetics study.
I can pick one of these if I want to learn
more about it.
If I am interested in sequence data, and notice
that I can narrow this down by what kind of
data available, so I could pick, for example,
whole exome if I wanted to.
I'm gonna go ahead and look at this study.
If I click on the main link there, it takes
me into the dbGaP information about the study.
I can see it is a sub study of this larger
one, and to get authorized access I'd have
to look at the larger study to see what is
required.
There is public information available on the
ftp site, the rest is controlled access.
I can read about what it is.
This is looking at people that have insulin
insensitivity, basically they had cases and
controls.
Whether they are case or control is based
on glucose tolerance results and fasting glucose
levels.
We can go back to take a look at the distribution
of those glucose levels, if we want to, by
using facets to find that particular variable.
Let me go back.
I will add a keyword to this.
I will add the keyword glucose.
Notice that as I construct my query, and I
didn't point this out before, I have these
little lozenges up here, these graphics to
show me how the query is constructed.
Now notice that I'm really interested in variables
that are associated with this.
What I want to do is click that tab and what
I can see is, I have fasting plasma glucose
available.
And a 2 hour glucose from my tolerance test
here.
So let me go ahead and click on the Variable
page for fasting plasma glucose.
So here I have a nice graph that shows me
what the glucose levels are for the people
in the case group; people that are potentially
diabetic; and in the control group.
And here is the overall distribution of glucose
levels here.
That's a quick way to find out that information.
I am going back to the facets page.
Had I visited that page by opening a new link,
my previous search that I had would be here
and I'd hve to clear it to get results.
What I am interested in now is a different
kind of variable.
I'm going to be looking at something called
bilirubin, which is a breakdown product of
hemoglobin that's in peoples bloodstream and
excreted in the bile.
Some people are walking with fairly high levels
of bilirubin in their bloodstream.
I will look for analyses that are about Bilirubin.
I will select that, and I get 8, they are
from two studies.
One of them is the Framingham cohort study,
which is that longitudinal study that many
of you are familiar with.
And there is another one which is pretty interesting,
the National Institute on Aging Sardinia study.
This is looking at a population of people
living on the island of Sardinia; it's kind
of a population genetics study.
let me select that one.
Now I have two kinds of Bilirubin, fractionaled
and total Bilirubin, these will be genome
wide association results.
This gives me a convenient link to the Genome
Browser, which I'm going to show you in a
minute.
There is also a link here for the PheGeni,
the Phenotype Genotype Integrator, another
useful tool to browse and search for GWAS
results.
I will save time, I have loaded the Genome
browser, sometimes it takes a while to load,
I will show you what that looks like.
Basically gives me, if I click the link you
could see this.
This gives me the P values, basically, SNPs
that are in a particular position on the chromosome
and their association, in this case with Bilirubin.
If I click here I will load the browser that
shows me the P values, so those association
results here.
There is a cluster of them right here; in
a nice little linkage group between these
two recombination rate peak here.
They all map to a particular gene, a complex
locus.
This is one of the glucuronosyltransferase
genes that is present on chromosome 2.
This is actually a complex locus with a bunch
of different products.
One I'm interested in, I want to show you
down here is UGT1A1.
I can click over to the Gene database.
This is the UGT1A1 polypeptide, it is associated
with some conditions with high bilirubin,
one of them is called Gilbert syndrome, which
is a very common condition; in fact I actually
have that condition.
This is how to use the faceted interface to
find the different types of data in dbGaP.
Let me switch back to the slides for a minute,
just to show you a couple more resources that
may be useful.
Some links to some things.
So some additional tools, one I mentioned
today was the Phenotype Genotype Integrator.
This is a good way to look at association
results, like the ones we saw at the end.
There is also the dbGaP data browser.
That particular tool is relatively new and
requires authorized access.
For documentation, much of the dbGaP help
is linked to the homepage.
Here are some direct links to it.
Tao has created a bunch of factsheets for
NCBI.
These are very useful.
I have a direct link there to the one on dbGaP.
A reminder that we have a YouTube channel.
This video and a number of other ones are
available there.
There is a link there to a README for all
of the factsheets.
If you have any questions about NCBI resources,
write to the helpdesk; info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
If you have any questions about our webinar
program, in other words, suggestions about
webinars that you would like to see or questions
about the webinars themselves, right to the
webinars@ address.
I will make sure everyone gets a link to the
recording when it is available.
Okay.
If there are no questions, I will go ahead
and wrap this up.
If you do have any questions or think of one
after the webinar, feel free to write to us,
the addresses are right there.
Thanks for coming and we'll see you next time.